we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine
to david p here is a call from dr ryan
i don't know why he's asking me about
this he's the doctor but it's a question
about masks take a listen
hey david dr ryan i had a question do
you think
that math will become a seasonal thing
and and basically a permanent feature of
society and here's kind of the context
for the question
okay so because we know conservatives
have pushed back against masks
they're pushing back against vaccines it
seems like we may not reach
full herd infinity and the virus can
continue
to mutate and it's just going to be
harder hard to control
and it becomes like the seasonal flu
that just keeps coming back
and now we have data saying that the
masks help it seems likely
in my mind that stores would turn on a
mask's required sign
in you know peaks season peak
covered season if it's going to be
something that's coming around every
year
i think that there is a real chance that
in
some parts of the country mask wearing
becomes uh seasonal and you know the
there's a very uh kind of ominous
article in the new york times that's
spreading about we
we may never reach herd immunity i i
think in practical terms
for this as a pandemic virus we will
reach herd immunity
i do think this could become and it's
not me i mean epidemiologists say this
could become sort of an endemic seasonal
thing
you might get a booster vaccine booster
once a year every couple years
like for the flu but i think that
i'm less sure about uh stores
saying oh during flu season you will
need masks to come in
maybe i think more likely as a first
step
you will just see people in high-risk
groups
that during flu season which seems to
correlate with
when you might see seasonal covet as
well
high-risk people might just start
wearing masks i know people now
who used to kind of be aware of flu
season as a time when they were at
higher risk but they didn't really
behave differently
who now are saying i think during flu
season i'll wear a mask to the grocery
store
between what is it october and uh i
don't
you know whatever flu season is there's
a few month period there
um i'm just going to wear a mask and i
think that
before we see stores go to some sort of
seasonal mask
thing we will just observe society
and see if there are people who either
socialize
less during flu season or where wear
masks when they go out
i think it's completely plausible and
the other thing i've said is there's
going to be a long-term psychological
impact of this pandemic
there are people who i mean listen there
are states now
where the coronavirus risk based on the
percentage vaccinated
is down to flu risk in the sense of
there are some states that
in a typical flu season have five deaths
a year that now we're down to ten covet
i'm sorry five deaths a day over the
course of the year
from flu that are now down to ten deaths
a day from covet
and as vaccination continues you are
going to see kova deaths get down to
the single digits same numbers as flu
that is not likely to feel the same as
before all of this stuff started and
what i mean by that is there are people
who are have realized thanks to this
pandemic
that they were maybe accepting more risk
before
during flu season than they're
comfortable going back to i think
there's no doubt about that
i think there will also be ptsd problems
agoraphobia people who just don't want
to be out there
they're just feeling i'm safe at home i
think i'll just stay home even if things
get better outside i think there's going
to be a lot of psychological aspects to
this
but i do think that dr dr ryan is uh
certainly on to something there
about the future of masks and that would
not the
the u.s would not be unique in that
there are lots of countries
where during flu season you see masks
worn just as a matter of
a matter of protocol i guess we would
call it we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today
republican senator tim scott is claiming
that congress is
close to a police reform deal is it true
and what would it look like also on the
bonus show
north korea is back and they are warning
the united states over joe biden's big
blunder do they need
food aid do they need medical aid
because of the pandemic typically
there's this cycle and that's when we
hear from north korea
and we are going to talk about maybe the
best argument
for increasing the size not physically
but the
number of members in the house of
representatives
the the size of the house chamber i
don't really care about it seems plenty
big
but the argument about the size of the
legislative body
what is that argument i will tell you
today on the bonus show we'll discuss
whether you think it's valid
and producer pat getting his second
vaccine dose today
how is he feeling how is he feeling we
will find out
in mere moments on the bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com coupon code
available if you want a discount it's
better21
we'll see you on today's bonus show